I will say I know on this website
somewhere there is one with the man in
the lizard costume let's find it yeah I
want to find that want us to put this on
yet or we are fast friends bad fur heads
it's worth saying I don't watch hardcore
porn basically ever I don't want to
watch people get hurt her other best
friend is a porn star
she just straight porn and I am a
bisexual woman anything what I can't so
what what's your what's your go-to
website to use like ages or pornhub I
also don't know what you disses I don't
usually watch porn with men in it so
really oh okay
Chris Tavano why don't you pick what
we're gonna watch you want to do you
just yeah the thing I like about you are
we in a private browser this guy's
saying that every everything he thinks
turns into a porn and he's that the
doctor trying to figure out the
situation we've got a man you know leash
his eyes are closed Oh Mina it's a penis
oh yeah you want to watch that one
that's the one if we don't want to watch
it that's the one we should watch I
don't want to watch brutalizing boys
love to be surprised by a boob a girl
doesn't want to be surprised by a penis
Oh better but I can't tell what she's
sticking it in she's bouncing but her
boobs are so big
you'd think she thought would hurt her
this is more exercise than I've ever
done she's in a crazy yoga pose too with
her legs over her head I don't want to
watch any more now I want to make you
unconscious no come on she was set to
yakety sax
[Music]
oh now we're on the gay part of the
website oh look at this one lesbian
seduces straight girl she's gonna try to
brainwash me what is this this is a CGI
porn - this one is r2d2 innit
yeah aren't you take our TV to shade the
one girls like I'm glad you didn't bring
your boyfriend along I thought the other
one was gonna begin oh okay um okay sex
is happening now pretty standard
okay she to the top is off yeah she
stopped fighting it well we also changed
locations a lot of stuff has happened
here's our house tiny boobs amazing
remember in uh in a new hope when our to
the little thing comes out so that he
can disable the tractor Beamer whatever
you just did that with a Dan of a dick I
mean that wasn't bad well it's just
funny I also like to make Allison freak
out so there's my ability to me like
welcome to my world here's weird things
that happen you know what I wish they
had more real romantic stuff you know
it's not usually like loving that's why
I wanted to show her the lesbian stuff
cuz that is more loving this is
obviously not the optimal porn viewing
situation
no porn is absolutely not a social
activity this is a man in his dark
bedroom with the door locked you might
put the volume down and I think it
appeals you to watch just like all
different kinds of people yeah I like
that
everybody is weird we're all weirdos and
anything you could want to find on a
porn site you could find it and it kind
of makes me feel like close to humanity
we're home just like yes we're all weird
freaks together so it's like when you're
watching porn you can't have a dick
that's like - like out there oh you
wanna you're gonna have a dick that
reminds you of your own dick I don't
want to think about the dick during it
it's too it's too much sounds like
you're thinking a lot about the day
sounds like that's what you
maybe I've seen that one which one